حلف الناتو اتفقنا على ان تكون
اوكرانيا عضوا في الحلف والمانيا
ترد وبوتين يلوح بنصر حتمي.
محاولة اوكرانية لغزو الاراضي
الروسية. قد انقلب السحر على
الساحر بينما القوات الروسية ترد
وبقوة. المجر احدث المنضمين لصف
بوتين ضد الاجماع الغربي وحلف
شمال الاطلسي. واكثر من ستمائة
وخمسين جنديا اوكرانيا في الموتى
خلال يوم واحد. شقيقة كيم تعلن
عن مفاجأة عسكرية والدم يتجمد في
عروق الجيران. وبعد ان اظهرت
الصين قوتها في معركة جوية
واشنطن تتودد. وايران تمد سوريا
بالسلاح لضرب القوات الامريكية.
الناتو يفجرها في وجه روسيا. بعد
ان ازداد الضغط على حلف الناتو
والضغط يولد الانفجار لتشتعل
الطاولات الاوروبية وتقول كلمتها
بصوت واحد. مرحبا باوكرانيا في
حلف الناتو. وذلك على لسان
الامين العام للناتو ان سولتمبرج
مصرحا بان جميع اعضاء الحلف
متفقون على ان اوكرانيا ستصبح
عضوا في الناتو. فمتى سيتم
الاعلان عن الانضمام رسميا يا
هذا. سولتمبرج لم يجب ولم يحدد
اي موعد. لكنه شدد على ان لا
تملك فيتو ضد توسع الكتلة
الدفاعية. مشيرا الى انه سيسافر
الى انقرة في المستقبل القريب
للقاء الرئيس التركي لمناقشة
انضمام السويد الى الحلف. ونحن
نعلم تحضيرات موسكو وتهديداتها
بهذا الخصوص. فكيف سيرد الروس
على هذا التحرك من الناتو?
لتستدرك هنا وزيرة الخارجية
الالمانية انجيلا بيربوك وكذلك
وزير الخارجية بقولهما انه لا
يمكن للناتو مناقشة توسيع صفوفه
وبحث موضوع انضمام اوكرانيا الى
صفوفه ضم النزاع في هذه الدولة
اي انه لا يمكن ضم اوكرانيا
للحلف قبل ان تنتهي الحرب وكأن
الغرب ينتظر ولادة مبكرة لفتاة
عذراء. بينما يواصل ستولتنبر
تصعيده ضد روسيا. ليعلن انه
سيزور انقرة في المستقبل القريب
لدفع طلب السوء الانضمام الى
الناتو بعد اعادة انتخاب الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوجان. لكن ما
لن هنا سؤال يطرح نفسه. ما الذي
استجد بعد اعادة انتخاب اردوجان?
حيث كان الرئيس التركي يرفض
تماما لانضمام السويد للحلف. هل
هناك امر يدار من تحت الطاولة?
وذلك بانتخاب اردوجان مرة اخرى.
مقابل الموافقة على ضم السويد
للحلف? سنترك الاجابة لكم. وهنا
كييف نحو خطوة اخرى. نعم انها
الهجوم خير وسيلة للدفاع حيث
اعلن الجيش الروسي انه تصدى
بسلاحه الجوي ومدفعيته لما قال
عنه محاولة غزو اوكراني لمنطقة
حدودية روسية شارك فيها عشرات
الجنود والدبابات. لتستخدم موسكو
الطائرات لردع الجنود الاوكران
بحسب بيان الجيش الروسي بينما
قال حاكم منطقة بلقرود الروسية
اشخاص اصيبوا في قصف اوكراني
خلال الليل على المنطقة. واضاف
المسؤول ان القصف اسفر ايضا عن
اضرار لحقت بالعديد من المنازل
والمباني جراء القصف. ليعود
ستولتنبرج مرة اخرى متحدثا عن
الضربات التي طالت منشآت مدنية
على الاراضي الروسية بان من حق
اوكرانيا ان تدافع عن نفسها. اما
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي اعلن ان تسعى
لان تمتلك كييف كل ما تحتاجه
للدفاع عن نفسها بينما تستعد لشن
الهجوم المضاد هذا الصيف. وقال
كيربي ان واشنطن لا تشجع الهجمات
الاوكرانية في العمق الروسي لمنع
تصاعد الحرب. فعن اي تصاعد يتحدث
بينما كانت الولايات المتحدة قد
اعلنت عن حزمة مساعدات عسكرية
جديدة الى اوكرانيا بقيمة
ثلاثمائة مليون دولار. اليس هذا
تصعيدا ايضا يتسائل الروس. ليأتي
الرد على لسان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين هذه المرة بقوله
انا واثق من ان النصر سيكون
دائما حليفنا. ولا يساورني شك
بشأن انتصارنا في العملية
العسكرية الخاصة وستكون بلادنا
في نهاية المطاف ضامنا للسلام
والامن. وبالعودة الى المعارك
على الاراضي الاوكرانية اعلنت
الدفاع الروسية خسائر قوات كييف
خلال اليوم الماضي شملت نحو
ستمائة وستين جنديا وطائرة سو
خمسة وعشرين وسبع عشرة طائرة
مسيرة بالاضافة الى عدد من
المدافع والمعدات العسكرية
الاخرى. لتدور الاحداث وتعود بنا
مجددا نحو الناتو. هذا الناتو
الذي لم تنتهي حباله في هذا
الفيديو حيث صرح وزير الخارجية
الهنغاري بيتر سيارتو بان تعتبر
تدريب الجيش الاوكراني تحت راية
حلف الناتو امرا غير مقبول.
معتبرا انه يجب على الحلف ان
يتجنب الصدام المباشر مع روسيا.
فهل يعد هذا التصريح اعلانا من
هنجاريا اي المجر بالانضمام الى
حلف بوتين بعيدا عن الناتو الحلف
الذي اعتبره الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون في الفين وتسعة
عشر انه في حالة موت سريري.
ليعود ماكرون ويقول هذه ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ايقظ الحلف عبر اسوأ صدمة من
خلال غزو اوكرانيا وقال ماكرون
امام منتدى جلوبسيك في براتسلافا
نحتاج اليوم الى مساعدة اوكرانيا
بكل الوسائل للقيام بهجوم مضاد
فعال. ومن صراع الناتو مع روسيا
الى تحضير الحلف لحرب ضد صربيا
الحليفة لبوتين حيث قال يا لدى
وصوله الى اوسلو حضور اجتماع غير
رسمي لوزراء خارجية دول الحلف ان
سبعمائة عسكري من الناتو توجه
الى كوسوفو لدعم قوات الحلف
هناك. الاحداث والتطورات. اكدت
كيميو جونغ شقيقة زعيم كوريا
الشمالية نائبة مدير ادارة
اللجنة المركزية لحزب العمال
الحاكم ان بلادها ستواصل جهودها
لاطلاق قمر صناعي وستضعه في
المدار الفضائي قريب جاء ذلك بعد
اعتراف بيونج يانج بفشل اطلاقها
صاروخا فضائيا يحمل قمرا
اصطناعيا للاستطلاع العسكري
وسقوطه في البحر بسبب خلل فني
وفق وكالة يونهاب. حث وزير
الخارجية الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
الصين على ابقاء قنوات الاتصال
مفتوحة بعد حادثة اعتراض طائرة
عسكرية امريكية فوق بحر الصين
الجنوبي. واعرب بلينكين عن اسفه
ازاء عدم انعقاد اجتماع على
وزيري الدفاع بعد رفض بكين وكان
الجيش الصيني اعلن ان طائرة
استطلاع امريكية توغلت في منطقة
تدريب عسكري فوق بحر الصين
الجنوبي مضيفا انه ارسل طائرة
لتعقب الطائرة الامريكية
ومراقبتها. ذكرت صحيفة واشنطن
بوست ان ايران تسلح سوريا لشن
هجمات جديدة على القوات
الامريكية وتعمل كذلك مع روسيا
على استراتيجية اوسع لطرد من
المنطقة. حلف النيتو الذي ظل
طوال فترة الحرب في اوكرانيا
يحذر من مواجهات مباشرة مع
روسيا؟ ها هو اليوم يذهب بقدميه
نحو تلك المواجهة؟ برأيكم هل
تشمر موسكو عن ساعديها لتبدأ
الرد على خطوات الحلف الجريئة.